my name is daniel van hoosen i'm a data
scientist scientific programmer at
impossible sensing
and today i'll talk a little bit about
space a little bit less about ocean and
really some machine vision techniques
that are guiding some of these
technologies
and i want to state that i'm not an
employee of nasa
impossible sensing is a startup company
here in st louis so um
yeah so i'll talk first about impossible
sensing and our exploration and science
technology
then i'll talk a lot about the mars
rovers and some machine vision
techniques on those rovers
a little bit less about the oceans and
relate the two at the very end so you'll
notice at the bottom of the screen
there's a little bar going across
and this represents the time it takes
for signal to be transmitted from the
earth to distant bodies
and so this is traveling at the speed of
light to scale so the first thing it
passes is the moon which it only takes
about two seconds to pass the moon then
when mars is at its closest distance to
earth it takes about 3.5 minutes for
signal to get there when mars is at its
furthest distance from earth takes about
23 minutes for light to get there
and uh the the fourth icon is jupiter
and it takes about 35 minutes to get
there so um if you intuit a little bit
this is just really a fancy way of me
timing my presentation
all right so impossible sensing was
found in
2016 by pablo sobron
and we develop custom optoelectronics
for sensing equipment and for analytics
and
our goal here is to implant these
devices in the most extreme environments
possible
and that includes in space and in the
deep ocean
and we're located here in st louis
so here are a couple of our our
technologies we really focus on
spectroscopy
so that's light-based interactions with
matter in order to determine things like
mineral content elemental composition
we also do custom optoelectronics
the top right hand corner is an example
of a lidar instrument we're working on
for nasa
uh bottom left-hand corner is a multi or
hyperspectral imaging camera
and then a couple of other technologies
include including surface enhanced raman
spectroscopy and a portable laser
induced breakdown spectroscopy
instrument so i've said a lot of
fancy words
but let's
let's uh really dive into it so say
you're interested in studying a
hydrothermal vent uh 1500 meters below
the surface
of the ocean
so what we're going to do is we're going
to send a bot down there and that bot
will contain some high intensity light
source like a laser
and when the light hits the sample it'll
interact with the matter in such a way
that it excites the the matter and then
that excitation will go back down close
to something called the lowest energy
state of the ground state and produce
light that we collect
and so in general there are lots of
energy states of matter
and
when the light strikes those they excite
them and then when the sample condenses
back down to some lower energy state the
energy difference gives off as light and
we collect that light
and so
that collected light as a function of
the wavelength uh gives us a fingerprint
for a material either an elemental
fingerprint or a molecular fingerprint
so these are a couple of examples of
raman spectroscopy
raman spectrum
the first is an antarctica extract
showing a signature of beta-carotene
and the second is a mineral
antihydrite anhydride
and there are of course a bunch of
different types of spectroscopy and the
two we focus on are raman and
libs laser induced breakdown
spectroscopy
so what's the motivation behind
exploration
so of course nasa wants to sustain life
beyond low earth orbit beyond where the
international space station is
and understand how the universe formed
in particular our solar system and
explore the potential for life inside
our solar system and elsewhere
and the lesser-known motivation here is
to support economic growth
and noaa and the ocean really have very
similar goals they want to understand
the earth better
to predict changes in climate weather
oceans and our coasts but they're also
interested in conserving and managing uh
marine ecosystems and the resources
within them
um so
uh in in in order to do that they have
to distribute this knowledge uh
including climate predictions weather
reports navigational information
and earth observations
so within that motivation there's a
subset for ai advancement which is
really required for efficiency and
safety of these instruments
so you can imagine some of the problems
associated with
deep space and deep ocean exploration
including latency and data transmission
budgets so if you look at the bar at the
bottom of the screen if we sent the
signal right at the beginning of this
talk it's not even a third of the way to
mars at its furthest distance from earth
and because of this
rovers and landers that are going to
mars have to be completely autonomous
until they get to the surface of mars so
it takes less time for
the lander to go through the martian
atmosphere than it does for signal to
get to mars
and so
these landers have to also be very
precise in their landing locations
in order for the rover to
easily be able to go to the specified
target
and so there'll be some machine vision
techniques i talk about which help with
accuracy of the landing site so then the
rover reaches the martian surface and it
has to be able to safely and quickly
explore
the
surface and for the ocean
ocean floor exploration is important and
necessitates ai
because of the vastness
and the efficiency so currently if you
want to
analyze minerals on the bottom of the
surface you send a dive bot you extract
a sample bring it back to a lab and
analyze it
but if we can make that autonomous and
in situ then it can be explored much
more quickly
and a couple of reasons we want to
explore the ocean floor
for minerals and biome mapping and
ecosystem mapping is because current
techniques for extracting minerals from
the ocean floor are destructive
mostly to the ecosystem
basically you take a large vacuum and
suck up everything down there and then
post-process and it's very destructive
so if we can map the biomes and the
ecosystems and the minerals then we can
make this more environmentally friendly
and of course these minerals are needed
for things like
solar panels and uh chips and etc
all right so let's jump right into it so
spirit and opportunity were launched and
landed around the same time
uh speared at the gusev crater because
it was possibly an ancient lake
opportunity at the meridian planum
because it's a location rich in hematite
which forms an association with water on
earth so the goal here is find water
find signs of biosignatures
spirit launched in 2003 landed in 2004
and the goal was to survey martian
mineralogy as well as search for
evidence of water
and determine if
the surface of mars was conducive to
life at any point
the mars exploration rover spirit used
solar panels and when fully illuminated
they produce 140 watts of power
and spirit's last contact was in 2010
and the reason for this was it got stuck
in a sand [ __ ] which we'll discuss
uh here a bit
opportunity uh launched 2003 landed
2004. same goal uh different location
and spirit and opportunity are
identical so they have the same
components again solar panels for power
all right so hardware and instruments on
the two rovers are identical
they both use an ibm rad 6000 flight
computer
and brad just means it's radiation
hardened it may not be state of the art
maybe five to ten years away from being
state of the art but it's been fully
tested such that nasa's convinced it can
withstand the radiation in space
both instruments have four pairs of
stereo cameras
for navigation and hazard avoidance as
well as for just imaging the martian
surface
and a host of other scientific
instruments including spectrometers
and
for
determining the composition of the
regolith in the atmosphere
so how do we get data from mars
each of the rovers has a couple of
different antennas one is for direct
transmission to and from earth
and that uses an x-band
and then you can also
ultra high frequency to a mars orbiter
so a satellite that's orbiting around
mars and then have much more time using
x-band back to earth and these signals
are detected on earth using the deep
space network
uh three satellites located
[Music]
in california madrid and in australia
and it's important to have a couple of
different methods for communicating with
a rover because the rover's only in
direct communication with earth for a
very short amount of time
and it's very slow data transmission so
this is for sending signals that
directly influence
the rover's decision making whereas uhf
and then transmission via expand earth
may be
scientific information or images or or
higher volume data
all right so let's jump into some of the
machine vision used for the landers and
rovers so early on in
the the rover development for spirit and
opportunity it was determined that
martian winds could be dangerous to the
landing
and
the way to mitigate this is to
understand in situ the horizontal speed
of these martian winds because you
couldn't know it a priori
so the way these landers did this is
they took three images during the
descent process
they processed these images projected
them onto a common plane and extracted
common features between the images and
from these common features they can tell
how much they've moved and two
positional points gives you a rough
estimate of your velocity and so they
can determine the horizontal velocity
and correct for
the martian winds
and in order to find features that are
common among each of the images they
just use the simple autocorrelation
similarity metric
and a harris edge detector which really
finds cont
parts of the image that have high
contrast differences
so these are the images taken by spirit
and opportunity as well as boxed out
features
that were used to calculate the
positions
and for spirit uh the estimated
horizontal velocity was 23 meters per
second too quick for a safe landing so
transverse impulse rockets slowed this
down to 11 meters per second
and for opportunity it was concluded
that uh it wasn't necessary to slow the
horizontal velocity
okay so the landers made it to the
surface of mars safely and now they need
to navigate and avoid hazards and do
what they're supposed to do on the
surface
and the way they do that is they're
stereo cameras so they take images with
the stereo cameras they develop a 3d
point cloud of the terrain that's around
them like the one shown here
they build a terrain map
based on the 3d point cloud
and they calculate paths of
possible routes to circumnavigate
the hazards
and each of these paths has an
associated cost
and the cost is associated with the tilt
of the ground if there are any hazards
there the time it takes to traverse
as well as the surface roughness and you
can turn them in surface roughness by
fitting a plane to the point cloud and
if there's large residuals or if there's
large error in the fit to the plane then
you know the surface is very rough
and then of course you want to select
the lowest cost path and drive some
short distance and it may surprise you
but it's only about a meter and then you
recalculate your world view via the
point cloud in order to calculate new
paths and new costs associated
and of course the spirit and opportunity
to use both combined human and auto
navigation
here are a couple of images showing
distance and height from the train maps
and here's a developed terrain map
showing hazardous locations red
orange is
safe to travel but be cautious and green
is
okay
so in addition to
landing and
navigating
safely and efficiently
scientists quickly
learned that the amount of data these
rovers were producing was very high and
they couldn't transmit all of that data
back to earth
efficiently so they had to find a way to
process the information in order to
select only the important data to send
back and so one example of this is the
detection of clouds and dust devils on
the martian surface
so what they did is they took sequential
images they subtracted those images from
each other and that highlights the
differences between the images or things
that are moving in the images and then
they said if the difference
between those images and the signal in
there was sufficiently high namely
greater than a couple standard
deviations away from the
noise in the image then something
important is in there go ahead and send
that back to earth
so
using a simple technique they were able
to identify important things
for the rovers to send back
okay so i'll talk just a touch about
curiosity and then move on to
perseverance which is the newest rover
just landed there this year
so curiosity landed in the gale crater
again signs that contained water in the
past that was the motivation
landed in 2012 and determine if mars
could have supported life characterized
climate and geology
uh and in this instance the rover didn't
no longer use solar panels instead it
used an rtg or a radioisotope
thermoelectric generator
which was 4.8 kilograms of plutonium-238
as the power source could produce 110
watts but it also had a battery backup
for
peak demand
all right so some of the hardware and
instruments were definitely updated on
the curiosity rover
now the cpus were
ibm red 750 cpus with 10-fold increase
in the amount of instructions per second
and it's a good thing it had two of
these cpus one of them is used as a
backup but about a year into the mission
one of the cpus failed so they had to
convert to the backup
and
this rover is still operational so that
that second cpu has been working ever
since
again stereo cameras for hazard
avoidance and auto navigation uh a
couple of other spectrometers for
science and i want to highlight the
chemcam or the laser induced breakdown
spectroscopy instrument our ceo helped
develop uh chemcam for this rover
so again for transmission um three
antennas x-band low gain x-band high
gain and ultra-high frequency
and
uh a couple of updates on the entry
descent and landing for curiosity
in this case it utilized the guided
entry technique in order to minimize the
amount of error associated with landing
and instead of having an airbag descent
like spirit and opportunity after the
parachute phase i was just too large so
i would use the power descent and sky
crane perseverance used the same thing
and auto nav in this case was largely
similar to spirit and opportunity
although there were some updates to the
software itself
all right perseverance
by far the most impressive rover so far
uh landed at the jezreel crater
and i want to take a moment just to show
you the images of the jezreel crater
which are really incredible so the blue
pins here are the ingenuity helicopter
as well as perseverance rover but the
reason they landed at the jezreel crater
really becomes obvious when we zoom in
here and this image looks like it could
have been taken on earth
looks like a river delta feeding into
some lake
obviously with no water there but the
reason they landed here was because of
this feature
all right so it landed this year
february
uh the jezreel crater and its goals were
largely similar to the other rovers
except it had a couple of other
techniques for extracting science from
the martian surface including sample
caching
collecting symbol collection and sample
caching
for a future rover to collect and send
back to earth again it used the rtg
power supply and of course it's still
operational
okay so um again it used the rad 750
cpus similar to curiosity uh it may be
confusing as to why
uh eight years after curiosity we're
using the same cpus but the reason is
they're not interested in the the
state-of-the-art cpu they're interested
in the most robust cpu it has to work
and so that's why occasionally uh it's
not state of the art but it's it's the
highest tested cpu that's used on the on
the rover
a couple of other instruments i want to
point out here are the moxie mars oxygen
experiment
this is a technology demonstration where
they extract part of the martian
atmosphere the co2 and they convert that
into oxygen
technology demonstration for future
humans to exist on mars
and then
impossible sensing is directly related
directly working with sherlock and
supercam
ramen and laser-induced breakdown
spectroscopy instruments
here's an example of a
data set from curiosity
perseverance has data sets available
but they're still being analyzed
so
uh the spectrum i'm showing here is
laser induced breakdown spectroscopy it
shows that the sample they looked at
on sol 2455 was manganese heavy iron
heavy had some silicon as well as
aluminum
and it's important to note that these
data sets from curiosity and soon
perseverance will be publicly available
at the pds geosciences which is hosted
by washu here in st louis
and pds's planetary data system
all right so
here's an image showing perseverance's
edl again it had the guided entry
parachute
descent as well as power descent and sky
crane techniques
but there's one key difference here
between this and the curiosity rover
during the parachute descent phase it
used a new technique called terrain
relative navigation
which is a machine vision technique
and they use this in order to
do real-time mitigation of hazardous
landing sites
so during the parachute descending
descent phase
the lander took images of the ground
processed these images
compared them to a database of images
from the orbiters that are going around
mars
and search for features inside these
images again using locations of high
contrast differences like mounds or
crevices things like that
found these features inside
the the map that they're comparing to
and extracted
the relative location compared to the
ground for a bunch of different points
so you have a bunch of different points
as well as time information you can
calculate a trajectory as to where
you're going to land if this landing
site is in a known hazardous location
then you divert
and
nasa predicted that the successful
landing probability went from 85 percent
to 99 using terrain relative navigation
so perseverance 2 landed safely and
begin navigating on
the martian atmosphere here you can see
a simulation of the first auto
navigation on the martian surface if you
look closely you can see various paths
being examined by the rover and it's
important to note this is sped up by 50
times so rovers really do navigate quite
slowly on the martian surface in order
to avoid hazards
so this had updated curiosity auto
navigation called enav or enhanced auto
navigation
so again the goal here is to take images
with the stereo cameras develop your
world view by world view i just mean
things that exist around you via point
cloud
develop a terrain map from that train
map calculate paths calculate the costs
associated with those paths and select
the lowest cost viable path
another thing that perseverance had that
the previous rovers didn't was called
visual odometry so as the rover's moving
across the martian surface it would
image the ground and extract features
from those images just like terrain
relative navigation and then based on
finding those same features in
subsequent images
it would know how far it had gone
so previous rovers actually used the
spin of the wheel to calculate distance
but like in spirit if you get trapped in
a sand trap and your wheel spins then
you think you've gone further than you
really have so visual odometry helped
correct that error
it's also important to note that the
enhanced auto navigation for
perseverance sped up the autonav by
about a factor of six from curiosity
which will have a top speed of about 20
meters per hour
and perseverance is a factor of 6
greater so 120 meters per hour
of course it uses
both its auto nav and planned
planned paths by people at nasa
okay so perseverance also had this uh
cool feature called the ingenuity
helicopter uh first time flight occurred
on on mars happened april of this year
so this is this is fresh
and this was a technology demonstration
so the reason this is important is
because the martian atmosphere is about
one to two percent uh the density of
earth's atmosphere and in addition to
that gravity is about 38 of earth's
gravity so as you can imagine flight is
extremely different from flight on earth
and in order to quickly
be able to explore the surface of mars
and other planetary bodies in the future
you need to use flight
you may also notice the processor for
the ingenuity helicopters
snapdragon 801 which is is a
state-of-the-art processor so using for
this tech demo nasa accepted some
additional risk that they wouldn't
normally accept and it's kind of funny
the snapdragon 801 has one to two orders
of magnitude more processing power than
the rover's processor
um
and and we'll see what the reason for
that is here in just a second
okay so this is an image of the
ingenuity helicopter from
the rover as well as a video of
uh ingenuity taking its
longest flight to date which was on july
5th uh 625 meters
this is a
video from the
navigational camera
and this navigational camera is doing
feature tracking while it's moving
across
the surface of mars
so
it's autonomous in the sense that it
wants to stay on a
a trajectory that's been planned out by
the nasa engineers and the nasa
scientists
and so those scientists and engineers
can't a priori know again the martian
winds or the environment on
the surface of mars so it has to be
autonomous to account for those things
so it uses a version of terrain relative
navigation called maven
where it tracks features across the
surface of mars
and in comparing these features across
subsequent images it's able to determine
its location very accurately it also has
a laser rangefinder to determine its
height from the ground
as well as an imu
to term to fix some of the other
constraints so ingenuity uses kalman
filtering which is just a probability
distribution of its current state
so its state is its xyz its position as
well as its pointing vector and its
velocity and things like the laser
rangefinder constrain a couple of the
components like the height to the z
uh but in order to constrain other
components you need to use this maven
feature tracking
and so this is a little bit different
from terrain relative navigation in the
sense that you don't need pre-pre-mapped
landmarks so it works with new terrain
which is important
and the goal here is to change your
rotor speed change your pitch in order
to align with the planned trajectory of
the flight path
and our signal just passed
uh
mars at its furthest distance so it
seems like it's going slow but it's
going at the speed of light
so future rover ai um
is important to talk about so there's
this
website you can go to called zuniverse
ai for mars
and uh on this website you can help
label images from perseverance and from
curiosity in order to create machine
learning algorithms for better auto
navigation
so rovers struggle to identify
non-geometric hazards like sand
and in fact i mentioned earlier spirit
got stuck in a sand trap and in addition
to that curiosity's wheels or were worn
down very quickly because it couldn't
identify locations of small sharp rocks
but with
this
crowdsourcing labeling for curiosity and
perseverance we can start to develop
things like spock or an onboard terrain
classifier
and and really identify places where a
rover could get stuck or where
small sharp rocks could be hazardous to
the wheels
another group is working on what's
called scotty or sole property and
object classification for onboard
terrain class
for onboard terrain
so these are images
that they're using to test
their algorithm with
so we might not always be able to send
back every single piece of information
due to the data limitations and the
trend data latency
budgets
but what we might be able to send back
is
text of what each of those images are
so here are a couple of examples of auto
classifying what's in the image
and vieger
another novel algorithm
which accounts for pathing
rover energy consumption so previously
the path cost was associated with just
hazards
uh just tilt
and time but it's also important to
account for rover energy consumption
across those pans
all right so in addition to rover ai
it's also important to introduce science
ai
and so
science instruments as well as some of
the imaging
technologies on these rovers produce
tons of data very quickly
and
what we need to do is reduce data for
transmission or reduce data for
efficient use by some of these
autonomous decision making algorithms
or auto classification
so we measure
then we down sample or encode the data
and uh we transmit or cl you have the
rover classify the information to
identify an important target or to do
something with that information
and then on earth or elsewhere we can
receive that information up sample or
decode and then analyze
the piece of science information and
what i've just described here is an auto
encoder just broken into two halves one
half here on earth for decoding and then
one half
on the rover itself for at the edge
processing
a couple of different ways you can do
data compression for efficient
classification or otherwise
of course there is principal component
analysis
but you might try some additional more
complex algorithms including fully
convolutional networks fully connected
networks or locally connected networks
to help preserve spatial information
and that's what we've done here the two
on the right are convolutional networks
one with a fully connected layer one
that's fully convolutional again the
fully convolutional layer helps preserve
spatial information
and we did this for raman spectrum
from
an open source database and found that
pca does pretty well but a couple of
techniques for cnns can actually do
quite quite a bit better uh details here
aren't super important but uh but some
of these are in the works
all right so
uh briefly talk about some space
challenges and then go into a bit about
the ocean
so challenges associated with autonomy
certainly at the
autonomous parts of the
space instruments can do no harm
certainly they can't do any harm to
the mission they can't do any harm to
the instrumentation of the hardware and
obviously they can't do any harm to
future humans who exist coincide with
these instruments
and another important component of
autonomy is understanding your bias so
of course each of these techniques is
developed
based on statistical uh methods
and so
if we're looking for example life
outside of earth but all of our models
have been trained on data from earth
then there exists some sort of earth
bias in the data and we may misidentify
something because of this earth bias
and there's actually a cool organization
called the laboratory for agnostic
biosignatures that's taking into account
this earth bias and trying to avoid it
when we search for biosignatures
on mars or or elsewhere
and of course some of the other
challenges include resources
computational resources as well as
latency and data transmission
and power
and the third thing to mention is
environmental challenges including
radiation and shielding
here on earth we have shielding from our
atmosphere we have shielding from
earth's magnetic field mars has a
sparse magnetic field but it doesn't
shield well and certainly
in the void of space there's no
shielding
and weather so as we travel to more
distant bodies for example the moons of
jupiter and saturn
the environments become
become more extreme and we have to
handle that
all right so uh future space missions
include uh going to some of the moons of
jupiter and saturn and the reason we may
want to go there is because they're
known to have an icy shell
and predicted to have water underneath
that icy shell liquid water underneath
that icy shell
and there's already a proposed mission
to europa
a europa lander
and the goal on this lander eventually
would be to study the expected
hydrothermal vents that exist
on the sea floor
in this liquid water
under the icy shell of europa and the
reason this is interesting to study is
because there's actually a theory here
on earth that
a german scientist proposed called the
iron sulfur world theory that suggests
that life started near or at
hydrothermal vents so hydrothermal vents
are
located in regions of high volcanic
activity at the sea floor and so there's
hot fluid mixed with minerals mixed with
salt the perfect environment
for for life to exist for life to start
and in addition to that
this is sort of the sleight-of-hand
segue into earth's oceans
we need to prove concepts on our on our
in our own oceans prove technology works
there before we can really take it to
these ocean worlds of the moons of
jupiter and saturn
uh so q
uh in the invader mission uh that
impossible sensing is working with seti
and the university of washington on
so the invader mission is to study
hydrothermal vents off the coast of
oregon at 1 500 meters below the ocean
floor here's an image of a hydrothermal
vent
and so we want to learn how life could
exist on these ocean worlds by studying
these hydrothermal vents and this will
be the first long-term real-time imaging
and spectroscopy payload
for underwater sensing
and so we answer technical questions on
the seafloor in order to enhance space
technology
and this will be deployed off the coast
of oregon
within the next year
which is pretty exciting so here's an
image of the instrument at our at our
current lab obviously it's it's not
completed yet
but but but it's uh but it's looking
pretty interesting so this is a
spectroscopy instrument um so it uses
uh raman spectroscopy to analyze the
hydrothermal vent
so
we're also interested in ocean floor
mapping for a couple of different
reasons
largely because habitats of minerals and
ecosystems
are largely unmapped on the seafloor
and as i previously mentioned extraction
of minerals on the seafloor is
devastating to ecosystems and these
minerals are really necessary for
producing environmentally friendly
technologies
such as solar panels so there are known
to exist these nodules
as you can see on the right-hand image
of precious metals precious minerals on
the sea floor and we want to map these
we want to map the ecosystems around
these
in order to
enable
non-destructive mineral extraction
and so these are just a couple of
concept images for what the invader
mission may look like we sort of
envision
these instruments as autonomous bots
maybe a swarm of autonomous spots
scoping out the sea floor
and reporting back to
something near the surface of the ocean
and the last thing i want to briefly
mention is a couple of techniques
that are being employed by noaa
in conjunction with nasa so not only
does ocean technology
uh
not only does ocean technology
interface with space technology but
sometimes space technology can be used
in the ocean and so
this dive bot from noaa called orpheus
technology demonstration
takes a terrain relative navigation used
on the ingenuity helicopter the maven
software and
deploys it at 6000 meters below
the surface of the ocean
and this is pretty cool because i can
autonomously explore
at very very deep points of the ocean
and
the software has been updated since the
ingenuity helicopter in the sense that
it now takes into account error
propagation mitigation
so you can take a look at the vio or the
visual inertial odometry software on the
jpl github page i encourage you to do
that
and a couple of conclusions here and
then i can take a few questions
so space and ocean exploration is
difficult
and autonomy is necessary in order to do
it efficiently and safely
certainly data transmission and data
latency play a factor in how quickly
humans can manually control instruments
that are very distant
and certainly ml and ai advance
the amount of science we can learn from
these missions
and for the ocean there's a lot we don't
know about our oceans we'd like to
improve on that
and enable exploration and tech
development that also guides space
research
and encourage
responsible ocean management and
environmental sustainability by doing so
so uh here's the impossible sensing team
um and the references
and uh that's that's pretty much it and
uh thank you
[Applause]
yeah sure thanks for the question the
question is
what is impossible directly working on
on some of these missions and so for
perseverance we're directly involved
with some of the science components
not really any of the machine vision
components although for the raman and
libs instruments
sherlock and sherlock and supercam
were developing technologies that allow
for us to use
auto classification on some of these
minerals and some of these elements in
order to enable the rover to
if it finds something interesting it can
go
maybe further investigate that without
getting approval from nasa first or if
it's just collecting too much
information
then it can condense that encode it to
send it back to earth and we can decode
it here so those are things we're
directly working on and in in the ocean
the invader mission and the viper
mission are in possible sensing missions
yeah so we're trying to do two things at
once oh sorry the question is um why
using ml encoders over traditional
encoders um so
so we'll we're definitely going to
investigate traditional encoders as well
but we're trying to do two things at
once uh one is to encode the data
efficiently
for transmitting back to earth
but but the other is to encode data
efficiently for classification or to do
something with uh immediately by the
rover and so this compression from ml
is really good for that and you can
really
change the ml algorithms in order to
do that efficiently
yeah so i glossed over that so it's
predicted to be between 1 and 10
kilometers thick
and there's a couple of different
techniques you probably need a
combination of both to get through it
one is sort of a laser based light
technique or heat technique
to go down through
it's expected to take about a year
the second is sort of a drilling
technique but of course as soon as you
introduce any mechanical component you
run into issues there
so those are in the works but of course
you also have to worry about
the ice is going to melt behind you so
the bot has to have some way to tether
to the surface
and they're thinking about placing these
pucks
in the ice as they go down that
transmits signal
based on the amount of space it takes
yeah so those are in the works but uh
extremely challenging
yeah probably an rtg uh plutonium source
um but uh they're obvi obviously uh
investigating other techniques as well
um there there is some other other data
but one reason in particular is the data
transmission budgets uh so when it first
lands there's a lot of hype they spend
the resources to send all that data back
uh but now they have to select between
science instruments imaging
and and telemetry
so it's sort of a balancing act but now
all the science instruments are kicked
up and working and those are also
producing data so you have to
balance
yeah okay uh so um
first question is uh is there any
possibility we'll accidentally bring
life with us and then detect it there
and yes it's a concern nasa is worried
about and certainly the laboratory for
agnostic biosignatures is working on
ways to mitigate that
but but one way to mitigate that is to
uh to make sure that you've prepped
everything in these very clean
environments and then once you send it
there
you need to test your instruments uh
look around look at yourself before you
look elsewhere in order to find life and
um the the second question was
um
maybe it'll become too challenging to do
different things and sort of maybe we've
reached the frontier and uh what are
what are sort of expectations there so
okay so
um
i don't think we've reached that point
yet so there's a couple of missions that
really excite me in particular
one is a mission funded partially by
nasa partially by facebook
they take these tiny little satellites
and they're going to shoot them
towards alpha centauri uh 30 to 40 year
mission using like a gigawatt laser or
something like that and solar sails
try and excite them to about 30 percent
the speed of light and 30 years from now
we'll hopefully get signals back from
alpha centauri so maybe in 10 years
something like that will be possible
but
in terms of the the frontiers i think
nasa has a goal to
go back to the moon with humans
in order to look at the polls there are
some interesting things at the polls a
lot of resources there and maybe the
polls could be sort of a bounding point
uh to future exploration so i don't
think we're quite at the point yet where
we can say
we
it's either too difficult to go further
or or we've done it all so
not in my opinion at least so yeah thank
you
all right i'll be on slack so feel free
to ask questions there thank you
[Music]
you